what 80s action star seemingly gets a
loving nod in the new love and thunder
trailer does thor's t-shirt have a
hidden meaning and which celestial
beings return from eternals keep
watching it's hard not to notice the
snazzy shirt thor sports during several
pivotal scenes in the trailer die hard
fans won't be shocked to learn that this
artorial choice may just contain a
deeper meaning which connects it to the
rest of the movie's plot as well as
thor's mythological roots the symbol on
the shirt an artfully drawn tree with
black trunk and black branches with
white circles all the way down placed
against a large red circle is most
likely a visual representation of the
mighty yggdrasil the world tree
norsemythology.org explains that
yggdrasil is a sacred and important part
to the spiritual landscape of the viking
world the tree supports the entire
universe its deep roots extend all the
way to valhalla while its strong gnarled
branches stretch above the clouds
yggdrasil's health is vital to keeping
the living world in harmony and the
cosmos depends upon it when yggdrasil
trembles or withers bad things are
headed asgard's way in the mcu the
original asgard is now just a memory but
as odin said
our scatter is not a place never was
this could be asgard
ascot is where our people stand
so if your sill does fit into the plots
of thor love and thunder the thunder god
may just be the right one to preserve it
eagle-eyed fans will remember that in a
previous thor love and thunder trailer
thor takes the time to meditate under a
tree that looks like idracil the thor
heads to such a sacred spot to attain
some sense of peace and guidance was
interesting enough but his idracial
t-shirt may indicate that enlightenment
is just what he finds there
the last time we saw a celestial
intervening in the mcu it gave cersei a
stern telling off before snatching her
in a selection of other eternals away
from the planet they just saved
you have chosen to sacrifice a celestial
for the people of this planet
now it's been confirmed in the final
trailer for thor love and thunder that
those cosmic colossi are going to make
another appearance just how big a part
do they play in thor's battle against
the god butcher in a frantic escape from
olympus we see the revengers going full
steam ahead and at risk of colliding
with two unnamed celestial beings even
though these celestials to work the goat
boat they still seem small compared to
the newborn celestial that nearly
hatched in eternals with that in mind
the celestials might be peaking their
head not through a window but a portal
of some sort or these are just decidedly
smaller than celestials we've seen in
the past size aside might these mighty
beans be a key factor in defeating gore
or given their antagonistic ways in the
past are they just going to be another
problem
traveling the universe can be a taxing
ordeal for those without an effective
means of traversing incredible distances
in the past the asgardians have used the
rainbow bridge the bifrost to almost
instantly teleport to various locations
this process usually scorches symbols
and runes on the ground this is the
reason why people on earth have a
mythology involving thor odin and loki
because asgardians have visited earth at
varying points in time and their
visitations left marks giving rise to
legends in norse mythology rainbows were
believed to be the physical embodiment
of the bifrost bridge unfortunately the
primary means of harnessing the power of
the bifrost was destroyed during the
events of thor ragnarok luckily though
it seems that thor and his companions
may have found a cool new way to invoke
the bifrost judging by this new trailer
their viking style longship appears to
be generating its very own bifrost while
it soars through the air which may mean
that the asgardians of the galaxy will
still be able to hop around the universe
with ease using a combination of the
boat and thor's goats who also have
origins in norse mythology whether the
boat's abilities are somehow connected
to stormbreaker remains to be seen
thor has wielded both mjolnir and
stormbreaker and can summon lightning on
a whim based on the latest trailer for
love and thunder he's also quite
flexible when two chariots fly at the
word super speed the god of thunder
manages to stop both vessels and their
tracks simultaneously by pulling off a
move often associated with belgian
action star jean-claude van damme thor
does an impressive split with one foot
on each chariot stopping both with
nerius sweat broken the move is
incredibly reminiscent of the splits van
damme would perform in his movies as
well as a 2013 volvo commercial where he
performed the act while on two trucks we
likely won't ever know for certain that
the thor moment draws directly from van
damme's resume but seeing how the
marketing for the movie has incorporated
the 1980s classic sweet child of mine
and the film features plenty of 80s
fashion it seems incredibly likely that
it's meant to be a reference
we've seen thor working with other
heroes in all previous trailers it's
been unclear whether there'll be a full
team up or just a bunch of individual
scenes the newest trailer confirms that
thor if no one else considers himself
the driving force of a very particular
team
i'm putting together the greatest team
ever in a voiceover that spans much of
the trailer thor introduces the latest
version of his revengers or possibly the
asgardians of the galaxy the team
consists of korg valkyrie jane foster
and the guardians of the galaxy which
currently includes star-lord rocket
groot drax nebula and mantis there's
also kraglin who seemingly is a
full-blown guardian by this point or at
least is close to getting there when you
combine all of that power and skill as
well as take into account the many
absurdly powerful villains the various
people in this squad have defeated it's
hard to imagine a villain who'd give
them any further difficulty it's also
kind of unnerving to think just how
dangerous gore the godbutcher must be if
thor has to put together this all-star
squad just to stand a chance check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the mcu
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]